there's no value in posturing or faking
the funk because you can trick the 98
percent and the two percent is who you
actually want and the two percent are
the ones that are turned off by your
[__] you're just tricking people
that are trickable because nobody has
ever tricked me ever ever in my entire
life well what am I one of one
definitely not and so I say to myself
then why would I do that and lose Equity
with the people that are most talented
just a trick the ones that are trickable
because when you're tricking trickable
people somebody else might trick them
onto you think about all the people you
try to be friends with in high school
because they were cool or good looking
and then like now just seven years five
years six years removed from it you're
like what the [__] you have no interest
in those people it's just that keeps
going on past High School